الكأس بعدما تخلى عنها وطردها من
المنزل. بين خطاب بايدن الذي قد
الاوكرانية التي خطفت الزوجة
البريطانية من شريكته تتجرع من
عضوة كونجرس قد توفيت. اين جاكي؟
امر باعتقال الشاب الكوري
البرلمان هي الاولى منذ شهرين.
وتم تسجيل اصابات في صفوف
اللهجة بسبب قصف الحرس الثوري
مناطق عدة باقليم كردستان في
كوريا الشمالية. وقالت هاريس
الصين تقوض العناصر الرئيسية
للنظام الدولي القائم على
القواعد وسنواصل دعم تايوان في
لتقدم اليابان والولايات المتحدة
اعتراضا مطالبتين بعقوبات جديدة
ان تحرير بالكامل على الاقل.
وهناك يسود الارتباك الشارع
الامر الذي يطلب من الزعماء
الاخرين الذين يقابلون بوتين.
خبراء استخباراتيون قالوا ان
الحمض النووي سيكون مفيدا في
صراعات القوى الدولية كوسيلة
للتجسس في عالم الاستخبارات.
هذا التخريب هم الاوروبيون
انفسهم وكذلك هي روسيا. فهل تكون
التسريب من هجمات على
النوردستريم. اسرار روسية هزت
امريكا هي التي فعلتها? ومن
سيثبت ذلك? وما يثير الغرابة
يسبب حربا عالمية وخطاب بوتين
المنتظر الذي قد يسبب الحرب ايضا
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يجهز تنفيذ
عمليات اغتيال من الجو في الضفة
موجة مظاهرات تعم ايران بسبب
وفاة الشابة ماسة امين اثناء
متسببا بانهيار سوق العملات
الرقمية. برلمان ولاية تورينجنا
الالمانية يتسلح بالبطانيات
لمواجهة البرد. اللاجئة
الجنوبي مؤسس العملة الرقمية
تيرا بتهمة نحو ستين مليار دولار
والايرانيين هذا? الاحداث
والتطورات. رئيس هيئة اركان جيش
ابنة الرئيس الاسبق رفسنجاني
بتهمة التحريض على احتجاج وسط
الخضراء في العاصمة العراقية
تزامنا مع انعقاد جلسة في
هم ضابط عناصر من القوات الامنية
اثر قصف صاروخي استهدف المنطقة
بهذا الخصوص. حرب الحاق الضرر
بالمصالح بدأت وان لم يؤلمك
الثمن. الان يطير الغاز في
الهواء. الى ذلك توعد الاتحاد
تسربا رابعا في واجتماع لمجلس
الامن بطلب روسي. موسكو من جهتها
هي في فما الذي يجري? العراق
تسلم سفير ايران مذكرة شديدة
الوقت الذي يعلن الجيش الامريكي
اسقاط مسيرة ايرانية كانت متجهة
احتجازها لدى شرطة الاخلاق فكم
سيستمر غضب العراقيين
الغربية بحسب وسائل اعلام
اسرائيلي بايدن مرتبكا الحضور عن
صينية في المنطقة المحيطة
بتايوان واضافت الوزارة ان عشر
العراقي الى غضب الشعب الايراني.
هنا اعتقلت السلطات الايرانية
المدى قبالة ساحلها الشرقي قبل
يوم واحد من وصول هاريس الى سول
التايوانية انها كشفت احدى
وثلاثين طائرة واربع سفن حربية
الاجتياح? غضب الشعوب. الشوارع
تكتظ بالمتظاهرين في العراق كما
الفاصلة بين الكوريتين.
وبالتزامن مع وصولها ها هو كيم
زعيم كوريا الشمالية نائبة
الرئيس الامريكي تزور المنطقة
العراق. الغضب العراقي لا يهدأ
حيث اصيب اربعة اشخاص في بغداد
طائرات صينية عبرت الخط الفاصل
لمضيق تايوان. هل اقترب وقت
الى بايدن طريق قد يؤدي الى
الحرب. شكرا امريكا تغريدة
اخرى غير الدولار فما الذي دعا
الهند الى تسريب هذه المعلومات
المتظاهرين خلال المواجهات وفقا
لمصادر عراقية. ومن الغضب
مجهول لافغانستان في ظل تدهور
الاوضاع. فهل نسمع تكبيرات
الى اربيل. والبيت الابيض يستنكر
القصف الايراني على كردستان
تشتري النفط الروسي بالدولار ولم
تدفع بالروبل الروسي او باي عملة
الروسي بعد اعلان التعبئة بينما
هنا كازاخستان تعلن استقبال
وذكر خبراء في علم الجينات ان
فكرة الحصول على الحمض النووي
الكريملين ديمتربسكوف ليقول
العمليات في اوكرانيا ستستمر الى
على كوريا الشمالية. نعم هي
الباسوس الاصدار الجديد. نائبة
الجنوبية. وكانت بيونج يانج
اطلقت صاروخين باليستيين قصيري
اربعة وثلاثين الف متهرب روسي من
التعبئة العسكرية. لا تلعب مع
يطلق صاروخا جديدا. بينما تجري
التدريبات الامريكية مع كوريا
لبلادها الصين وكوريا الشمالية
لتعلن هنا وزارة الدفاع
الدفاع عن نفسها. فهل فشلت نانسي
بيلوسي لتكون هي من ستشعل الحرب
الرئيس الامريكي هريس تشعل
التوتر مع الصين كما فعلت مع
الغربية فان واشنطن باتت تخشى من
انتصار اوكراني محتمل ما يعني
مع روسيا لاستيراد والقمح في اول
صفقة اقتصادية كبرى بعد عودة
لزعيم عالمي تبدو مخيفة اكثر مما
هي في الواقع. فهل هناك اسباب
هذا الفحص وبعد ان رفض الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الخضوع
لفحص كورونا في موسكو خوفا من
حصول روسيا على حمضه النووي وهو
روسيا تلمح الى تورط واشنطن
وتشير لتصريحات سابقة لبايدن
الاوروبي برد قوي على اي تعطيل
متعمد للبنية للطاقة في القارة.
في اتفاقيتها مع موسكو. حرب
بوتين الجديدة. كل الطرق تؤدي
دليل عمليا على انه يقترب من
استخدام الاسلحة النووية. لكن
الاستخبارات المركزية الامريكية
سي اي ايه يرد من الصعب للغاية
كيم. ها هم يستفزون المجنون
والمجنون لا يرحم. وبسبب صواريخ
اخرى لهذا الفحص لا نعلمها في
الاثناء خرج المتحدث باسم
والدهشة اكثر هو ان الاستخبارات
الامريكية حذرت قبل اسابيع من
العالم. اذا كنت زعيما واردت
لقاء بوتين فما عليك الا اجراء
نوردسترين باشعال اول شرارة
للحرب. فالمصالح قبل كل شيء لهذه
تقول هذه مشكلة كبيرة بالنسبة
لنا لانه اولا خطي نوردسترين
الدول. تبادل الاتهامات في سماء
الطاولات السياسية بين موسكو
امريكية وبعد اكتشاف ثلاثة
تسريبات للغاز. السويد تعلن
طالبان في شوارع اوكرانيا? وهل
يستغل بوتين نفسهم الطويل
لتقع طالبان في احضانها. باسعار
منخفضة وقعت حكومة طالبان اتفاقا
يشكرهما على ذلك. ومن السياسة
الى الاقتصاد. وكل منهما يؤدي
وخبرتهم في حرب اوكرانيا? شيء في
هذه الحياة يعطى دون مقابل. ليس
اقتصادية. قالت مصادر مطلعة ان
شركات التكرير الهندية لا تزال
والغرب بشأن تسرب الغاز من خط
وبين هذا وذاك فان الخاسرين من
لسياسي بولندي ملحقة بصورة لتسرب
الغاز فهل هو اعتراف بجريمة
كل الحلفاء اوفياء. وبعد اردوغان
حليف اخر لبوتين يوجه له ضربة
خطابا هاما اثناء المراسم. فهل
تتدخل الدول الغربية؟ مدير وكالة
الرصاص سيؤلمك جيبك وما لم تفعله
معارك اوكرانيا قد يفعله
بوتين سوف يشارك في مراسم ضم
المقاطعات الاوكرانية وسيلقي
اقوى سيدتين في اوروبا تقولان
لزلنسكي اعتمد علينا في هزيمة
الاخرى. ومن التهديد بالقوة
العسكرية الى القوة الناعمة هنا
بوتين. انهما رئيسة البريطانية
وزعيمة حزب اخوة ايطاليا والتي
ممتلئان بالغاز. النظام باكمله
جاهز لضخ الغاز والغاز باهظ
اسعار السلع العالمية. وذلك بعد
ان حذرت الامم المتحدة من مصير
تخشى الحرب اكثر من غيرها يا
سادة فتجاهلوا كل التصريحات
خسارة روسيا لاهدافها الاساسية
من الحرب هنا يرى الامريكان ان
الدفاع الامريكي بنظيره الروسي
لاول مرة منذ بداية الحرب
الروسية بينما يأتي القلق
الامريكي من هنا. وبعد تراجع
الحركة الى السلطة بعد عرض روسيا
على ادارة طالبان خصما على متوسط
الى القوة. وبعد ان استخدمت
روسيا اسلوب الاعلانات المصرية
فازت بالانتخابات البرلمانية ولم
يملك الزعيم الاوكراني الا ان
ورؤسائها؟ وبعد ان تلقى الضربة
الاولى من تركيا ها هو بوتين
الحرب. وبعد ان نجح الجراح
الروسي في استئصال الاراضي
يتلقى الضربة الثانية من احد
حلفاءه. وهنا تندلع حرب من نوع
الاوكرانية ها هو اليوم يحضر
لحفلة تاريخية هي اشبه بحفلة
الحرب فمن سيحضرها ومن سيطفئ
شموعها؟ حيث ذكر الكريملين ان
السلاح النووي لتتحول الازمة الى
حرب عالمية حديثة. ما دفع وزير
بوتين اصبح في مأزق وما يخشونه
هو ان يدفعه ذلك الى استخدام
في مجلس الامن. والعراق يبدأ
باول اجراء لحفظ سيادته لتسقط
الروسية الاوكرانية. لمباحثة
الامر حتى لا يسوء الوضع. امريكا
وبحسب صحيفة بوليتكو فان واشنطن
تكثف مراقبتها للاسلحة النووية
القوات الروسية وتحول للهجوم
بدلا عن الدفاع بفضل الامدادات
الكفتين والمجنون يضع على الجرح
ملحا لتصيح واشنطن باعلى صوتها
جديد بين امريكا وروسيا فمن هو
السبب؟ الجواب لدى روسيا؟ والصين
تستفز امريكا بعد ان كانت هي
التي تستفزها. فهل اختل زان
اوكرانيا هل تفلح النساء يا ترى?
طالبان تقترب من روسيا فهل نسمع
يستفز المقاومة الفلسطينية? فهل
تعود صواريخها الى تل ابيب? حفلة
تكبيراتهم تدوي في اوكرانيا?
واجراء اوكراني يقلق امريكا فما
هنا اول طائرة ايرانية. فبماذا
سترد طهران وتصريح اسرائيلي
القول في هذه المرحلة ما اذا كان
بوتين مخادعا لكننا لم نر اي
هذا الاجراء؟ ولم تاخذ موسكو
عينات فحص من زعماء الدول
الاخيرة. بينما هو في الجانب
الاخر يفرض الامر الواقع وواشنطن
تراقب عن بعد. فما الذي يجري
وبعد فشل رجال اوروبا بانقاذ
هل يوجد خطاب يؤدي الى السلام?
هنا ينتهي الاستفتاء ليكتم
العالم انفاسه وينتظر كلمة بوتين